protesters are ready for Dalia Oregon is
hilarious they put out a [__] article
protesters are ready for Delia dude they
wrote an article about it
so I'm like oh [__]
okay I guess I'm still relevant
if people are this mad hey I did the
show
people showed up
two
two people showed up
hey media shoot dude
the two people showed up and they
disguised their faces
I'm showing myself on stage and so are
2800 delivers
show went [__] gangbusters dude
we love it dude don't push me you're
trying to push dude
you trying to push
so here we go
two right wings dude
you got a [__] fly it around in
a circle dude
what am I supposed to do quit my job no
dude not if 2 800 people are gonna show
up crazy crazy
congratulations
[Music]